نعود الى الوضع الانساني في خانيونس ينضم
الينا الدكتور احمد المغربي رئيس قسم
جراحه الحروق في مستشفى ناصر دكتور علمنا
بان اعداد كبيره من الشهداء تصل الى
مستشفيات خانيونس منها مستشفى ناصر ماذا
عن حاله المصابين دكتور طبيعه الاصابات
التي
تصل نعم
اي يمكن نحن كلنا متابعين الوضع داخل
مستشفى ناصر هو صراحه مش من صباح اليوم من
امبارح بالامس بدا القصف العنيف في في
منطقه خانون س وتحديدا حوالين مستشفى ناصر
اليوم الصبح صراحه من حول الاعداد اللي
وصلتنا داخل مجمع ناصر اعداد المصابين
والشهداء انا كرئيس قسم جراحه التجميل
اضطريت انه انا اسكر العمليات اللي بتخص
اللي هي جراحات التجميل والترميم المجد
ولا واضطرينا نلغي حوالي 20 حاله كان
المفروض اليوم اعمل لهم عمليات واخذ واخذت
معاي ما تبقى من الطقم الطبي من ممرضين
وغيره طلعنا على العمليات الكبرى فوق في
الطابق الرابع عشان نشتغل في العمليات انت
يمكن بتعرف الان المستشفى محاصر والطواقم
الطبيه اصلا كده هي ما بتقدر توصل لمستشفى
وعددنا الان قليل و صراحه الوضع سيء ومتعب
جدا لانه الطواقم الطبيه صراحه الان صار
قليله داخل المجمع بسبب هذا الحصار اعداد
المصابين صراحه كانت مهوله اليوم اي اجتنا
اصابات متنوعه كثير من شده القذائف
اصابات بتر في الاقدام في الاطراف العلويه
في الصدر في البطن يعني مصبات متنوعه كانت
صراحه في ظل الحصار الخانق كما تفضلت
دكتور ما الذي يصلكم من مساعدات
طبيه اه يعني سؤال هذا صراحه نن دائما
بيسالونا اياه سؤال صعب جدا جدا المساعدات
الطبيه بتوصلنا يعني من كذا مؤسسات دوليه
يعني اخرها انا بذكر وصلنا مساعدات من
منظمه اليام اساف اللي نحن اصلا بنعمل
معها وانا فرد منها منظمه الهئ مساف اي
هذا الحكي يمكن من شي اسبوع وصلنا منه
مساعدات طبيه لكن بعتقد ما بعرف في ظل
الحصار الان على المستشفى هذا يعني
الموجود الان حتكون الامر صعب انه يوصل اي
شيء من هذه المساعدات الطبيه المساعدات
الطبيه صراحه لازم تدخل كل يوم داخل
المستشفى لانه نحنا بستهلك مواد طبيه كثير
كثير بشكل رهيب يعني بالذات انا في قسمي
قسم الحروق وجراحه الترميم نحن بنستخدم
مستلزمات يعني فوق فوق فوق الوصف يعني ما
بقدر اوصف لك شو ننا بنستخدم اشياء صراحه
في العمليات وفي الغيارات وغيره يعني
دكتور نعلم بان قوات الاحتلال تعرقل عمل
الاطقم الطبيه بل وتعتقل ايضا ايضا اطقم
طبيه في مستشفيات اخرى في ظل هذا الواقع
ما امكانيه وصول واجلاء الجرحى والشهداء
من مكان القصف هل هي
متاحه صراحه يعني يمكن انا بدي اتوسع في
هذا الموضوع
شوي يعني لو بدنا نحكي عن موضوع الطواقم
الطبيه ووصولها داخل المستشفى يمكن ح
تفاجا لما انا بحكي لك الان متواجد عندي
انا في في قسم جراحه التجميل والترميم
عندي طبيب من لندن انجليزي وعندي ممرضه
ممرضه من سكوتلاند طبعا وصلوا هم هنا غزه
عن طريق مؤسسه
دوليه بصلنا ه صراحه كان وفود
اجنبيه بشكل كان مستمر يوصل الوفود
الاجنبيه تساعدنا
اي انا انا ح جاوبك على سؤالك طبعا بعد ما
خلص كلامي انا صراحه بقنا ششد اطبائنا
العرب انا لحتى الان في قسمي ما شفت ولا
طبيب عربي موجود عندي في المستشفى او حتى
يسال عبر السوشيال ميديا شو بتحتاج او شو
بيلزمك احنا كل كل الاهتمام اللي بيجينا
من الخارج بالالاف الرسائل اللي بتوصلنا
من اطباء من اطباء اجانب للاسف ولا طبيب
عربي انا انا اتحداك اذا انت بتذكر لي اسم
طبيب عربي وصل عننا هنا قطاع غزه او عندي
تحديدا في المستشفى وحكى لي شو بيلزمك
برغم الصعوبات والمصائب اللي احنا قاعدين
بنعيشها ولا طبيب عربي يعني وين الضمير
العربي معقول يعني الاجنبي الاجنبي عنده
اهتمام بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اكثر من الطبيب
العربي والمواطن العربي هذه مصيبه اللي
بتصير يعني ولا طبيب عربي انا اتحداك اذا
بتذكر لي طبيب عربي وصلي ه المستشفى
يساعدني انا لحالي الاست الاستشاري الوحيد
الموجود داخل الان مجمع ناصر في تخصصي هذا
جراحه التجميل والحروق ما فيش حدا سال ما
في ما في ما في هذه مصيبه وامكانيه اصلا
انه حدا يطلع ننقل جرحه الان من مستشفى
ناصر هذه مصيبه اكبر ما بنقدر نقال نطلع
اي مريض من مستشفى ناصر كيف بدنا نطلعه
الان ننا محاصرين
محاصرين شكرا لك دكتور احمد المغربي رئيس
قسم الحروق في مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس